bonjour j'ai osé avant dit merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin en
direct sur rt france avec cette
situation en afghanistan qui évolue très
vite on l'a vu reprise des combats dans
la vallée du panjshir aux mains des
talibans ce matin qu'est ce que ça
implique selon vous
bonjour merci de votre invitation
je dois dire que déjà en ce qui concerne
la vallée du panchir les
informations ne sont pas vérifiées
réellement il faut dire que en ce qui
concerne l'afghanistan la communication
et quand même contrôlé par les talibans
et que la situation est très confuse
dans la vallée du panchir il n'y a que
des communications privées qui donne
quelques nouvelles en particulier
d'ailleurs hier soir est tombée la
nouvelle de l'assassinât et de la mort
de farine dashti qui était un compagnon
de route du commandant massoud et
également des lois route sahara qui
était son neveu
néanmoins les rumeurs les informations
contradictoires ne permettent pas de
faire une idée claire de ce qui est en
train de s'y passer sauf que d'une
certaine manière les talibans sont
entrés dans le panchir que les combats
continuent que les talibans sont
soutenus par un grand nombre de
puissance et que les pannes chéri se
trouve aujourd'hui très isolée et malgré
leurs appels à la communauté
internationale ils sont
délaissés et se sentent délaissés par
tout le monde si cette reprise de du
panjshir se confirme vous avez raison
précisé que les informations sont
parcellaires qu'est ce que ça veut dire
est ce que l'afghanistan est sous
contrôle total des talibans et qu'est-ce
que ça impliquerait
alors effectivement le panchir et la
poche de résistance
de manière générale depuis très
longtemps dans ce pays
si l'information se confirme on doit
imaginer qu'il y aura des combats qui
continueront parce que la résistance ne
va probablement pas baisser les bras et
donc on peut imaginer une hypothèse qui
serait une poursuite du dac d'une
confrontation entre les talibans et les
combattants du panjshir un don est-ce
que la crainte d'une guerre civile
soulevées par les états unis est
justifiée selon vous et bien si il n'y a
pas d'accord entre les pannes shihri et
les talibans on va tout droit vers une
guerre civile bien évidemment alors à
kaboul il y à un retour progressif si je
puis dire à la vie normale avec la
réouverture de l'aéroport les talibans
qui qui doivent encore nommer un
gouvernement il devait le faire ce
week-end ça a été reporté et les femmes
afghanes qui elle théoriquement prennent
le chemin de l'université ce matin avec
des restrictions est extrêmement stricte
qu'en pensez vous
eh bien vous l'avait bien dit c'est un
calme provisoire qui se met en place à
kaboul même si déjà il y a eu encore des
attentats ce week end des attentats
sanglants qui ont eu lieu à kaboul la
vie reprend il y a des communications
aériennes se sont mis en place les
lignes privées d'où en tout cas afghanes
auraient commencé à circuler et les
universités seraient ouvertes néanmoins
néanmoins nous sommes sous une
talibanisation de kaboul et
effectivement les femmes même si
officiellement dans les discours on leur
accorde un des petits bouts de liberté
comme la possibilité de participer dans
un futur gouvernement mais dans des
rangs très peu élevés et de rentrer à
l'université
cela m'inspire beaucoup de craintes
malgré tout pour la situation des femmes
parce que les exactions envers les
femmes n'ont pas cessé les
manifestations des femmes ont été
réprimées très durement et le contrôle
des femmes il ne faut pas l'oublier
reste quand même un élément central de
des talibans et donc de la future
politique envers les femmes qui à mon
sens procède d'une invisibilisation des
femmes afghanes de manière générale
elles sont obligées de porter la burqa
pour pouvoir revenir à l'université qui
étaient les cours cinq minutes avant les
hommes et attendre justement que ces
sommes soient sortis de l'enceinte de
ces universités pour pouvoir sortir elle
même avec une condition sur les
professeurs également est ce que
finalement toutes ces restrictions ne
vont pas sonné le glas de la permission
des femmes d'aller à l'université
est ce que vous vous pensez que
l'inclusion prenez par les talibans dans
ce nouveau gouvernement à venir et
crédible
il faut dire que l'inclusion prônée par
les talibans est à destination
de la communauté internationale est
taliban veulent rassurer la communauté
internationale inquiète un rapport à la
situation des femmes mais également donc
c'est un discours qui est destiné à
rassurer certains afghans eux mêmes
néanmoins quand on voit que
d'après certains discours les talibans
annonce qu' ils sont encore dans une
situation il faut protéger les femmes
des exactions et de l'insécurité
régnante cela me rappelle exactement le
même discours qui avait été prônée lors
de la première prise de pouvoir des
talibans qui exactement pour les mêmes
raisons
estimait que les femmes ne pouvaient pas
accéder à des travaux ou à sortir dans
le à l'extérieur pour des questions de
sécurité
ce qu'il faut ajouter c'est que malgré
tout ce qu'ils mettent en avant c'est
qu'il doit y avoir une ségrégation entre
les hommes et les femmes est donc cette
ségrégation par exemple au sein des
universités va être difficilement
atteinte dans la mesure où il faut assez
de profs femme pour pouvoir accueillir
des jeunes filles étudiantes femmes et
donc les conditions
de travail éventuellement si tout cela
se poursuit vont êtres vont être très
difficiles et que donc il y à aussi de
manière prévisible des heures qui vont
avoir lieu en raison de
l'inaccessibilité
pour certains talibans et hommes afghans
de la participation des femmes que ce
soit à l'université ou à d'autres
niveaux au gouvernement comme vous
l'avez dit chirouze et en avant en avant
dit on a parlé de déclarations
modéré si je puis dire des talibans en
ce moment à à l'intention de la
communauté internationale également en
avion angela merkel qui dit qu'il faut
dialoguer avec les talibans sont pour
autant évidemment les reconnaître
oui en effet c'est de toute façon la
communauté internationale et en
particulier les européens sont devant le
fait accompli et donc la seule voie
possible semble pour les occidentaux de
maintenir le dialogue avec les talibans
de manière à éventuellement à travers
des négociations pouvoir obtenir un
certain respect de quelques droits qui
restent encore possibles dans la
communauté enfin dans chez les afghans
et donc par ailleurs de pouvoir utiliser
une seule arme qui existe à savoir là à
la pression financière puisque comme
vous le savez les avoirs afghans sont
gelés
l'aide internationale entre autres du
fonds monétaire international est bloqué
pour le moment et donc la communauté
internationale à travers les contacts
diplomatiques
semblerait-il et ceir est de garder un
oeil sur ce qui se passe dans la région
en tenant compte également que les pays
voisins sont en tractation et sont
beaucoup plus puissants dans la région
que les occidentaux vous avez parlé du
qatar mais il ya également le pakistan
et d'autres pays l'iran également la
chine entre autres si également les
afghans dont l'enjeu majeur sera
évidemment de reconstruire le pays ils
ont besoin justement de ce maintien du
dialogue avec les occidentaux pour
relever ce défi
ils ont besoin d'argent et donc pour
pouvoir stabiliser la situation
économique qui est catastrophique il ne
faut pas oublier que la moitié plus de
la moitié des enfants vivent en dessous
du seuil de la pauvreté de la situation
agricole
environnemental économique de manière
générale est catastrophique donc s'ils
veulent obtenir une certaine légitimité
dans la population ils sont obligés
également d'avoir les moyens financiers
entre autres et de ne pas couper les
ponts avec la communauté internationale
qu'est ce qu'il en sera une fois que le
gouvernement sera rétabli encore faut-il
voir quel type de gouvernement il va y
avoir un en afghanistan
il parle d'une d'un gouvernement
inclusif de coalition on aurait dit en
d'autres temps mais la participation des
afghans et des arcanes de tous bords est
loin d'être acquise et même si il y à
des branches différentes des talibans
qui y participent
on ne sait ni quels seront leurs places
et on ne sait pas non plus avec qui ils
vont former ce gouvernement
beaucoup de noms ont été cités au début
de la chute de kaboul on a parlé de
l'ancien président karzaï et du docteur
abdullah abdullah ils ont disparu pour
le moment des radars on parle avec
matière en terme de non talibans mais
avec matière fait partie d'une branche
des combattants afghans encore plus
radicale sinon aussi radicale que les
talibans eux mêmes donc toutes les
questions restent posées pour le moment
il va falloir qu'on peut gérer
évidemment avec les tribus qui joue
aussi un rôle majeur en afghanistan bien
évidemment un élément central de la
compréhension de la situation afghane
c'est cette présence de multiples tribus
de différentes
composantes à l'intérieur également des
tribus parce que il n'y a pas de
position homogène dans ce pays ni à
travers parmi les tribus ni à
l'intérieur des tribus il faut aussi
ajouter que en afghanistan les alliances
se font et se défont et donc encore une
fois je pense qu'il est un peu trop tôt
pour pouvoir dire quelle sera la
situation
dans un moyen terme ou dans un terme
plus long merci beaucoup en tout cas
firouzeh en avant dit d'avoir répondu ce
matin à nos questions sur rt français
d'avoir décrypter la situation actuelle
en afghanistan